When you are sealed with the name of
God, the temple of God, new name of
Christ,
that means
that
you belong to God. You're marked as his
possession, his property.
When you are sealed with someone's name,
that's ownership.
That means you belong to that one. You
are his property.
You are his.
You know how you write your name on,
let's say,
your
book. You write your name inside,
whatever it is.
Or you write your name on the back of
your credit card,
right? That name signifies this is
yours, it belongs to you.
Now that name
>> [clears throat]
>> that God writes on you is the mark that
he seals you with. Now, watch. I'm going
to tie it in with Tertullian
and what he saw.
Then I looked and behold, the lamb was
standing on Mount Zion, and with him
144,000
having [clears throat] his name and the
name of his father written on their
foreheads. See? That's the mark. You
know how the beast will mark you with
his name and the number of his name on
your right hand and the forehead?
God will mark his true followers with
his name sealed on their foreheads.
Now watch how it's going to tie in with
Ezekiel 9.
Revelation 22:3-4,
okay?
And there will no longer be any curse,
>> [clears throat]
>> and the throne of God and of the lamb
will be in it, and his slaves will serve
him. They will see his face, and his
name will be on their foreheads. Now
watch the magnificence
of these early Christians.
One more. Talking about the 144,000
Israelites.
Okay?
Revelation 7:3,
saying, "Do not harm the tree, the
earth, or the sea, or the trees until we
have sealed the slaves of our God on
their foreheads." You see the sealing?
You're sealed by the Holy Spirit in
baptism with the name of God, Father,
Son, Spirit,
and you're also sealed
with the name of the city of God,
meaning you are
a descendant
of Abraham spiritually because you
belong to the true seed of Abraham, the
true Israel, Christ, and you are now a
spiritual Israelite, and therefore you
belong to heavenly Jerusalem, your
mother. Galatians 4:26. Jerusalem above,
she is free, she's our mother. Hebrews
12:22-24.
You've come to heavenly Jerusalem.
Revelation 21:1-2,
19-27.
Jerusalem coming down from God like a
bride adorned for a husband, coming out
of heaven to now engulf the earth.
You see? So,
the seal will say, "Property of heavenly
Jerusalem. Property of the new
Jerusalem. Property of the Jerusalem
above."
Right?
You see how it works, right? The sealing
is real.
It is not fake, it's real.
God spiritually seals you, and by faith
you believe it.
Okay?
But now here, the angel is saying, "Seal
the 144,000
from Israel before you destroy the
earth." Cuz this is going to be relevant
to Ezekiel chapter 9.
And you're going to be blown away.
And through this I saw four angels
standing at the four corners of the
earth, holding back the four winds of
the earth, so that no wind would blow
>> [clears throat]
>> on the earth
or on the sea or on or any tree.
Then I saw another angel ascending from
the rising of the sun, having the seal
of the living God, and he cried out with
a loud voice to the four angels to whom
was granted to harm the earth and the
sea, "Do not harm. Do not bring
destruction.
Do not inflict these punishments on
rebellious sinners until
the remnant of God are sealed." Why?
The seal will be the sign
that they are God's,
and God will not destroy them in his
wrath. Understand?
Let me explain something to you about
Revelation.
In Revelation,
sorry. [clears throat]
It's It's going to come out in Jesus'
name.
It's a slap. In Revelation, there are
two wraths.
Two.
God's wrath on the wicked and the wrath
of the dragon, Revelation 12.
You understand?
There are two wraths.
Okay?
Revelation 12, when Satan is barred from
heaven, thrown to the earth, and no
longer allowed access to heaven,
it says, "Woe to you
on the earth." Revelation 12:12.
"For the dragon's wrath is great, for he
knows his time is short."
And [clears throat] he goes and tries to
unleash wrath on the people of God.
So, if you didn't know it, now you know
it.
There are two wraths in Revelation.
The wrath of God on the wicked,
which [clears throat] we do not
experience cuz the seal marks us
for salvation,
and the wrath of the dragon on the
righteous.
You with me there?
Everyone got it? Okay.
Now, there's a foreshadowing to this.
There's a foreshadowing in the Old
Testament of God's wrath being poured
out on the wicked, rebellious,
unregenerate Israelites,
but his wrath
being
>> [clears throat]
>> circumvented,
sparing
the righteous,
the holy, obedient, faithful remnant
from that wrath.
And where do you find it? Ezekiel 9.
You with me so far?
All right.
Let me just remove this now.
Ezekiel 9.
God's wrath will be poured out on the
wicked, unregenerate, [clears throat]
rebellious Israelites, but not on the
righteous remnant.
So, what does God do?
He has the righteous sealed
with a mark.
Okay? Watch here.
Ezekiel 9.
Then he cried out in my hearing with a
loud voice, "Draw near,
>> [clears throat]
>> O executioners of the city."
Spiritual creatures. Each with his
destroying weapon in his hand. Behold,
six men were coming from the direction
of the upper gate. These are spirit
creatures. Each faces north, each with
his shattering weapon in his hand, and
among them was a certain man clothed in
linen with a scribe's case at his loins.
Notice, he's got a scribe case, meaning
he's got
ink and a pen.
Ancient pen, not the pen we use today.
And they went [clears throat] on and
stood beside the bronze altar. Then the
glory of the God of Israel went up from
the cherub on which it had been to the
threshold of the house of Yahweh. He
called to the man clothed in linen
at whose loins was a scribe's case.
Yahweh said to him, "Go through the
midst of the city, even through the
midst of Jerusalem, put a mark
Here's that seal. On the foreheads. You
see, nothing new under the sun.
Revelation is re- reiterating, repeating
what's in the Old Testament.
You guys see that?
Why you got to know your Bible?
God, the same yesterday, today, forever,
always seals his servants with a mark.
Who sinned, sighed, and groaned over all
the abominations which are being done in
its midst midst.
Right?
But to the others he said in my hearing,
>> [clears throat]
>> Yeah.
"Go through the city after him and
strike. Do not let your eye have pity
and do not spare." Notice who's
destroyed? Those who don't have the mark
on their foreheads.
Right?
The mark on their foreheads.
See that?
You got it, right?
Then behold, the man clothed in linen at
whose loins
>> [clears throat and cough]
>> was the scribe's case, responded with
words saying, "I've done just as you
have commanded me. I've marked them."
Now here's what Tertullian saw.
Here's why it's always good
to either get a good commentary or
consult the Hebrew. Okay?
You You want to see what he saw? And I'm
going to blow your minds away with this.
I don't know if some of his right hands
are asleep, but watch here.
You got I want you to see what he saw.
What [clears throat] Tertullian saw,
which again baffles me cuz I don't know.
Did he see it in Latin? Because this is
in Hebrew.
Oh, nine. No, I didn't put eight. Dude,
nine, not eight.
Watch here.
Guys, get ready to now be blown away and
shocked.
The cross of Jesus has always saved from
the beginning.
The cross of Jesus
is the means that God has saved
everyone. Do you know that? Here it is
in the Old Testament in front of our
eyes.
You know what the word mark is? It's the
Hebrew letter
tau, which in modern Hebrew is tav.
Tau,
which in modern Hebrew is tav. You know
why you're going to be in awe right now?
Because in Paleo-Hebrew,
the tau, the tav looks like a cross.
You don't believe me? Here it is.
You don't believe me? Here it is. Let me
get you the link so you can click on it.
In Paleo-Hebrew, ancient Hebrew,
the tav looks like a cross. Yeah. It's
right here.
It may not go through. It's too long.
But nonetheless, click on it.
Rumble, let me get it for you, Rumble.
Did you get it, Rumble?
Click on it [clears throat] if you can.
Here it is, right here.
Do you see it right there? Let me
enlarge it a little bit for you.
The Paleo-Hebrew letter tav represents
the 22nd
and final letter
of the Hebrew alphabet circling as a
cross.
See that?
Even here, you see it.
Cross.
The mark of protection, Ezekiel 9:4.
I'll show you the images.
See?
Where is it? Why didn't they show it?
Okay, anyway.
This [clears throat] must have the
picture here. I don't see the picture.
Oh, I got to be a member. Okay, shut up.
All right, let's go here.
You're telling me this is a coincidence?
There it is, the cross.
See that?
Here it is.
See?
Let's see if they have it on the stone
here. Yep, you see?
Ancient Hebrew alphabet.
Here's it right here. There's the cross,
the tav or the tau.
Right here.
See?
You go right here,
you'll see it.
Right here,
the T.
You saw what a Tertullian saw?
You guys see it?
You saw what Tertullian saw?
>> [clears throat]
>> You saw what Tertullian saw?
He [clears throat] said, "This is the
cross of Jesus Christ."
This is the
cross of Jesus Christ that saved them.
Right here, right?
Ezekiel 9:4.
Ezekiel 9:4. Let me see if I can find
ancient list.
You see?
It looks like an X, but it's also a
cross.
See?
See what he saw?
See that?
So you see,
how did God save them?
He saved them with the cross.
What did God say? Mark them with the
cross on their foreheads.
Mark them with the cross
on their foreheads.
Rumble, you see that or you don't see
that?
Do you guys see that?
I got this from Tertullian,
and I looked [clears throat] it up and I
go, "Oh my goodness."
If you believe what
you just saw with your eyes,
God has always been pointing to the
cross of the Lord Jesus Christ.
Jesus our Lord
was saving them on the merits of the
cross that was still future because from
God's perspective,
the future for them,
it's a present reality.
So if you ask me, "Sam, how were they
saved?" They were saved by the grace of
Jesus Christ.
"How were they forgiven?" They were
forgiven by the blood of Jesus Christ.
Okay? "What are you talking about?" I'm
giving you Bible, dude. I'm not making
it up.